We're on problem 43.
Which statement describes
the graph of
the following equation?
They write x squared plus y
squared plus 4x minus 6y minus
3 is equal to 0.
Essentially you want to get
this into standard conic
square format-- I don't know
what it's officially called--
and you do that by completing
the square on both the x and
the y I guess you could call
it sub-polynomial.
Then you should be able
recognize what kind of conic
section it is.
So let's separate out the x
and the y terms. So the x
terms-- I'll do that in blue--
you get x squared plus 4x.
Then we're going to add
something that makes it a
perfect square.
You can already guess what
we're going to add.
Let's say we're going to add 4,
because x squared plus 4x
plus 4 is x plus 2 squared.
So I'm going to write that in
magenta just so we remember
that we added it.
This came out of nowhere
right now.
So if I added plus 4 here,
I'm going to have to add
plus 4 on this side.
This is the equals sign.
All right, then let me do the
y terms. I'll do it in this
brown color.
Plus y squared minus 6y.
Then what would add here?
Half of minus 6 is mine 3.
Then if I were to square that,
minus 3 squared-- I'll do it
in this magenta color
again-- is plus 9.
So I want to add plus 9 to the
right-hand side as well.
Of course this is y minus 3
squared, this whole thing
right here.
Then I have that minus
3 right over here.
All right now let's rewrite
this term right here.
I added this plus 4 here for a
reason so that I could make
this into x plus 2 squared, then
plus-- and I added this
plus 9 here for a reason,
so I could make
this y minus 3 squared.
Let me just keep the minus
3 there for now.
Minus-- let me do it in the
other color-- minus 3 is equal
to 4 plus 9.
4 plus 9 is equal to 13.
Let's add the 3 to both sides
of that equation.
So you get x plus 2 squared
plus y minus 3 squared is
equal to 16.
Now if you think about it, this
is the form of a circle.
x minus a squared plus y minus
b squared is equal to r
squared, where the center of
the circle is at where?
Whatever the x-value is what
makes this equal to 0.
So it's x, it's minus 2.
Then the y-value of its center
is what makes this equal to 0.
Minus 2 comma 3, that's
its center.
It's radius is the square
root of 16.
So the radius is equal to 4.
It can't be negative 4.
You can't have a negative
radius.
So the answer is a circle with
radius at minus 2 comma
3 and radius 4.
That's choice D.
Problem 44.
What is the solution to
the equation 5 to the
x is equal to 17?
OK so that means that we if we
take the log base, so five to
the x power is equal to 17.
We could rewrite this
in log format.
That means that log base 5 of
seventeen is equal to x.
You could read this exactly the
same way you read that.
5 to the x is equal to 17.
Of course that's not one of
our choices, and this is
fairly useless on your
calculator because you don't
have a log base 5 button.
Let me write it this way, x is
equal to-- I'm just switching
it-- log base 5 of 17, just
because it's easier
for me to deal with.
I prove it in previous Khan
Academy logarithm videos, but
there's just a general
property.
I'll write the property here.
If x is equal to log base, I
don't know, base b of a, that
is equal to log base 10 of a,
lowercase a, divided by log
base 10 of b.
You just have to pick
the same base.
You could have the base, you
could have the natural log of
a divided by the natural
log of b.
You could do whatever log you
want, but log base 10 is on
your calculator.
So that's why this
is convenient.
So we could say this is equal
to the log base 10 of 17
divided by the log
base 10 of 5.
That should be a choice.
Yep, that's choice D.
Next question.
This problem 45.
I'll write it down, 45.
They say if log base 10 of x is
equal to minus 2, what is
the value of x?
So that essentially --
10 to the minus 2
power is equal to x.
All a logarithm is, it tells you
what exponent do I have to
raise the base to to get
whatever I'm inputting into
the logarithm function.
Right So if I raise 10 to
the minus 2, I get x.
10 to the minus 2, that's 1 over
10 squared is equal to x,
which is 1 over 100
is equal to x.
That's choice C.
I think I could do problem
46 right here.
46.
Which equation is equivalent
to log base 3 of
1/9 is equal to x?
OK, read it the exact same
way we read question 45.
This is just saying that 3 to
the x power is equal to 1/9.
Let's write that.
3 to the x power is
equal to 1/9.
Is that one of the choices?
Yeah.
That's choice C.
That was suspiciously
easy, I think.
You just have to know
the definition of
what a logarithm is.
OK problem 47.
I'll clear the screen.
Let me switch colors.
47.
Oh I'll cut and paste this one
because this is interesting.
Let me pull it up a little bit
so you can definitely read it.
Because they want us to identify
an incorrect step.
OK let me go here.
OK they ask us, which is the
first incorrect step in
simplifying log base
4 of 4 over 64.
All right step 1, they said log
base 4 4/64 is equal to
log base 4 4 minus
log base 4 64.
That's right.
When you divide within the
logarithm function or when
you're inputting into the
logarithm function, that's
equivalent of taking the log of
the top one and subtracting
from that the log
of the bottom.
Actually when you divide two
numbers of the same base, you
subtract their exponents.
We've proved that in
previous videos.
But that's just good enough
that you need to know that
that's the correct
step right now.
So what's the log base 4 of 4?
4 to what power is equal to 4?
Yeah sure, that's equal to 1.
4 to what power is
equal to 64?
Let's see, 4 squared is 16.
4 to the 1 is equal to 4.
4 squared is equal to 16.
4 to the third is 4 times
16, which is 64.
So 4 to the third power is 64.
So this is 3.
So this should be-- let's see,
log of 4 minus 16-- right,
this should be a 3 here.
This should be a minus 3.
So this step 2 was the
first incorrect step.
They mis-evaluated
log base 4 of 64.
They through it was 16
for some reason.
I guess they divided 64 by 4.
But it's actually 4 to the third
power of 16, sorry, 4 to
the third power of 64.
So the answer there is 3.
So step 2 is the first
incorrect step.
Next question.
All right let me see.
All right, clear image,
invert colors.
Let me copy and paste this
one too because this is
interesting.
I'll try to copy and paste
as many of the
word problems as possible.
This is problem 48.
Let me write that down
in the corner.
48, right in that corner.
Jeremy, Michael, Shanan, and
Brenda each worked the same
math problem of the
chalkboard.
Each student's work
is shown below.
Their teacher said that while
two of them had the correct
answer, only one of them had
arrived at the correct
conclusion using
correct steps.
OK they want to which is the
completely correct solution.
OK let me just copy
and paste those.
So the completely correct
solution, OK so let's just
think about what everyone
did here.
It looks like this is it
dealing with exponents.
All right he had x to third
times x to the minus 7.
OK this is already wrong.
Because x to the minus 7
is 1 over x to the 7.
This is one over x to the 7.
So this should be a
plus right here.
So he's wrong.
OK Shanan, x to the third
times x to the minus 7.
Yep that equals x to the third
over x to the positive 7.
Then let's see, 1
over x to the 4.
That is right, right?
Because this is equal to
x to the 3 minus 7.
So that's x to the minus 4.
x to the minus 4 is
1 over x to the 4.
So as far as I can tell,
Shanan's work
looks pretty good.
Although this was a little weird
how she went straight to
1 over x to the 4.
She may just skipped a step.
Michael's work, x to the
over x to the minus 7.
OK, he made the same
mistake as Jeremy.
X to the minus 7 when you put it
in the denominator becomes
x to the positive 7.
Not right.
Then Brenda's work got
this step right.
But then this should be
x to the minus 4, x
to the minus 4 power.
So this is not correct.
So the only person who got
it right was Shanan.
What choices is that?
Shanan is choice C.
Out of time.
See you in the next video.